foreign
is in Atlanta hi Robert welcome to the
Ramsey Show
thank you so much for taking my call
sure how can we help
so my wife and I have found ourselves in
an unsafe house we believe and so we're
we're thinking that we're going to have
to move
um really ASAP what's wrong with the
house
well so we just we didn't really do our
research up front we had a baby that was
due within a couple of weeks by the time
we uh we bought it and so we brushed in
to upsize and make room for the baby but
the location just kind of is is more
unsafe you know we hear a lot of crime
activity going on around us
um you know gunshots every now and then
so
that's kind of the gist
what was the event that broke the
camel's back what was the latest thing
they went I got to get out of here
yeah well I think within the first two
weeks you know we had our cars broken
into
um
yeah there you go okay sell it get out
get out of Dodge this year live in Dodge
City
I shoot up and down the street
right right yeah right that's it get out
of Dodge no pun intended but yeah really
do it yeah
I mean and it doesn't matter how much we
sell it for well I mean you don't have
to panic
uh I mean do you have any money it's
important not urgent yeah do you have
any money might be urgent I don't know
yeah we we've got about thirty thousand
dollars uh liquid what'd you pay for the
house
we paid 345. okay call a Ramsey call it
Ramsey trusted real estate endorsed
local provider for Real Estate sit down
with them and tell them that you want to
sell the home and what is a reasonable
period of time a reasonable price for
the house to sell in 60 to 120 days
okay and then the shot in the and then
decide do I want to go ahead and move
or or can I make it that long
okay understood can you make it that
long are you do you feel safe enough to
stay two or three more months or do you
need to go ahead and move now
well I we've we've been there for six so
you know six or three more months
probably could happen six months
right and two cars got broke into okay
foreign
right that's that's right yeah okay
y'all talk about it because listen if
they're shooting up and down the street
and they're breaking into my cars and I
got a new baby I'm gonna go rent go rent
an apartment and move
and put it up for sale and when it sells
I'll talk about buying somewhere else
but right now we may not even buy
just go get go get in go get your family
safe right you got to get out of the
freaking war zone
right am I missing something
no the other the other question was just
you know is renting an option you know
if we were to move you know renting is
fine because we need to you know build
up some capital for the next down
payment and we can take our time be
calculated with the next one of course
yeah yeah but you know if we yeah is
renting an option yeah the current one
you know that yeah to start with it's
your only option right now
if you move out this weekend because you
don't feel safe
okay so you're gonna be renting a while
and that's okay but if you say it we're
going to rent for two years build up
cash and Slow Down slow our roll and get
a better you know get a much more
diligent
careful process when we buy next time
sure yeah I'm sorry I may not have been
clear I guess the current house given
that the atmosphere is changing that
area appreciation could be a thing in
the next few years and so if we could
hold on to that no no
if we have to move because our family is
not safe we're not counting on
appreciation
okay
that's just you live in Dodge City no I
mean the cool people are living there
but the cool people are not scared of
the bullets okay that's fine you got
hipsters next to gangsters I got it okay
but that that's one of these
gentrification neighborhoods but this is
okay you can do that but you told me
with the start of the call you have a
new baby and as a dad you don't feel
safe
so if you don't feel safe don't invest
in the area
okay 10-4 understood thank you so much
get out of Dodge man
yeah it's that and also you know yeah if
you guys don't feel safe
of course then move like like your peace
of mind is is
is very important in that way
they're part of Nashville though that I
mean there is there's a lot and it is
four or five areas on my hand right now
yeah and people live there and they're
expensive houses you know what I'm
saying so and some of them are nice
houses and it's the top it's the
tolerance level of what feels right to
you so that's what I'm saying it is the
difference in a boomer and a millennial
I think so for sure
no boomers are going to live next to
gangsters and call it fun Millennials
think it's funny I don't understand
these hipsters next to gangsters for me
it makes no sense
but it's everywhere I get it I see it
happening and it's the regentrification
neighborhoods is the nice way of saying
it but um and there you know it and he's
right if it continues and enough people
don't get killed in the process then if
it can I also think we will be a huge
investor in Nashville in a suburb of now
like it's a we are we're in a suburb
yeah but I just saying like we have
friends that have moved here from
Chicago from other areas and yeah you
hide your per like it's just like
there's a different safety measure of
how they're used to living life than we
are so like I'm saying your tolerance
for all of that is very low which is not
wrong no but I'm also saying to Robert I
live next to gangsters it doesn't matter
when you're shooting up and down the
dadgum street and you call it fun I mean
I don't get this not you not you but I'm
just saying people some people have a
higher tolerance
for where they live and so but Robert
that's what I'm saying it's so
individual and if Robert and his wife
aren't comfortable they're not
comfortable the car being broken into
when they have a new baby that makes
them normal yes
that makes them smart yeah I mean I hear
you but I'm also hey I broadening
childhood friends of yours bought house
door kicked in robbed the whole place in
one of those neighborhoods right after
you got married I remember the story
okay won't name the name we're on the
radio but the uh yeah this stuff it's
it's it's it boggles a Boomer's mind
I'll just tell you you I get it
intellectually emotionally I don't
understand why not go somewhere else I
don't get it it's a company lives in
there dude probably I don't know but um
yeah it just it's it's crazy and the one
the fun one have you seen the Nashville
judgmental map oh gosh don't stop
we're moving on I don't even know I
don't want to know I'm nervous I'm
starting to it's making fun it's making
fun of us out here it makes fun of every
neighborhood okay and and so it's an
equal opportunity offender and it's
great it's like this one's gangs this
one's gangs that kill cats this one's a
hipster trust fund babies why this one's
Boomers this is Boomers like Ramsay you
know I mean it's like it makes fun of
everybody it's hilarious oh I think it's
funny I sent it to one of my buddies who
bought a house in one of those
neighborhoods yeah
so
you gotta have fun with this y'all gotta
have fun with it I I truly think that
that is that is a difference
generationally that I have seen that
um that is way different because the the
generations prior to mine and then mine
were suburbanites and they came to the
suburbs for a safe they left but yes
they
left the farm or they left the inner
city to come to a safe bubble and then
the generations following are going back
into those areas and regentrifying them
uh and living in them and that's what
he's dealing with that's what he's
dealing with yeah so it's very
interesting